Hello,
and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode Live.
I'm your host Rawkode,
and I am very pleased today
to be covering the Cortex project, a time
series horizontally scalable time series database, which is
part of the cloud native foundation as an
incubating project.
I wanna first thank my employer, Equinix metal.
They give me the time to invest in
making this show and producing content that we
can all learn together with. So thank you
very much to Equinix metal.
They have given me a code, Rawkode dash
live. You can use this to sign up
for the bare metal cloud and get $50
of compute time. Now you can use that
$50 you know wisely and use smaller boxes
and have lots of compute time Or you
can splurge it really really quickly in a
few hours with some massive bare metal machines.
So you know, pick your poison.
We have a Discord community where we allow
people to chat about these episodes afterwards. So
if you're not watching live and you have
questions, feel free to drop in and chat
to us there. Of course, if you are
watching live, please get involved. Leave us comments
in the YouTube section, the YouTube comment section
and we'll be happy to tackle them as
we go.
As I said, we're gonna cover Cortex today
and I have a fantastic guest with me.
So let's bring in
Ganesh Vernikar. How are you Ganesh?
I'm good. How are you, David? Yeah. I'm
very well. Thank you very much. So you
are an engineer at Grafana,
a maintainer on a Prometheus project and a
contributor to Cortex.
Can you just
but maybe add a little bit of flavor
to that. Tell us a little bit more
about Grafana, please.
Yeah. So I'm a software engineer at Grafana
Labs, as David said, and I have been
a maintainer of Prometheus project since one and
a half years. And I maintain the TSDB
part of the Prometheus and sometimes work on
the PromQL part. And since I joined Grafana,
because we have Cortex as our
back end for the hosted solutions,
I also contribute to Cortex regularly.
So that's about the background that I could
say. Nice. I mean, not just a maintainer
or Premiere, but the actual TSDB section as
well. I mean, it takes a very special
kind of person to build a database and
work on a database. So let's say, I'm
glad it's you and not me. That's for
sure.
So
can you tell me
just,
you know, when it when it comes to
Cortex, right, there there are many flavors of
Prometheus
kind of,
I don't know, evolutions, I guess. You know,
other projects that are using Prometheus as a
core and API and and adopting some of
those best practices that Prometheus has kinda brought
forward
as we all adopted cloud native and and
Kubernetes. So can you just tell us why
Cortex
exists? What what space is it trying to
fill inside of here? Yeah. Definitely.
So,
this Cortex or any other project like Thanos,
m three, Victorimetrics, etcetera, they don't aim to
replace Prometheus as is, but they extend what
we
do with the Prometheus data.
Before we can talk about why we need
Cortex, we let's
talk about what's
lacking in Prometheus and what this gap is
in. Actually, made some notes so that I
don't forget telling something in this. Yeah. So
first, talking about the global view. Let's say
you have Prometheus in multiple Kubernetes cluster,
and you want to have a global view
of all the Prometheus that you have installed
in multiple clusters that you have. That's
actually doable in Prometheus, but there is something
called Prometheus Federation
where you run another prem Prometheus which scrapes
the existing Prometheus and you scrape out of
Prometheus. But still, are limited by what Prometheus
can do in a single machine, which is
super high, but still there's some lacking. But
let's say you want to do So
you have two Prometheus scraping the same stuff,
and you have a federation
on those two Prometheus to have a global
view and multiple other Prometheus.
But, again, if you have a single Prometheus
for federation, that's single point of failure, and
you don't have So
we'll have for Prometheus. So you can see
where it's going. It's getting kind of messy
handling
multiple Prometheus.
So that's one of them. Cortex
acts as a centralized database where you have
all the data of all the Prometheus of
your cluster, and you have a centralized view.
Another thing, multitenancy.
So when you are a large large organization,
you would like to have diff you like,
you have different teams, and sometimes you might
want to give access to a team for
some part of the return, not everything. And
Prometheus is not, multi tenant natively.
So Cortex is multi tenant natively where if
you've you can say that some part some
group of Prometheus servers are of one tenant,
some are other tenants, and everything is again
in a centralized store.
And, yeah, Prometheus scales very well vertically.
And
but there is a limit
of how much memory or how much CPU
that you can have.
So Cortex
fills that gap by having
a horizontally distributed database where it can scale
horizontally unlimited
metrics.
So those are a few things that I
can see right now. Yeah. Awesome. Those are
things that I think, you know, as, you
know, as so many people are adopting Kubernetes,
horizontal scalability is now almost just something that
we we we take for granted.
Yeah. And well, at least in some applications.
But when it comes to databases, this is
a completely different domain, a completely different problem
and a really good space that Cortex is
trying to kind of fill a void
and and solve some challenges. So I'm really
excited to see
how we can get started with Cortex and
how we can use it for all of
our our metrics. Yeah.
Okay. So
we're going to
I think today's a little bit different from
normal. We're gonna split this into multiple sections.
So we're we're gonna cover the installation of
of Cortex and some hardware that I preconfigured.
So Let me get my screen on.
So this is Equinix's little console. I have
spun up two bare metal machines, Cortex one
and Cortex two. I don't know if we
need them, but that's alright. I'd like to
have them available.
Now I believe we're gonna run through getting
started on one of these machines.
Yes. And then you wanna cover a little
bit of the architecture, which I'm super excited
for. And you think you've got a demo
and then we're gonna try and
rebuild that demo ourselves on this computer. That's
an array. Okay.
Awesome.
So should we Or maybe we could we
could be bold and just do all the
demo in your machine itself. It should be
simple.
I mean, I I do like to be
bold. Yeah. Definitely.
I've broken a few things on this show
before. I'm not I'm not scared of doing
that again. So Yeah. Shall
what do wanna do first? Shall we get
Cortex installed on one of these machines and
go through the Yeah. Let's,
yeah, let's get started with the doc. So
in the document, you can click on documentation
and and
click on getting started. We have all the
steps that we can do. And click on
block storage, which is going to be the
next default storage, which does not involve an
index tool.
Okay. So First thing, yeah, first thing is
to clone the repo.
The RubyFace repository?
No. Cortex. Cortex. Got you. Got you. Yeah.
Yeah. You can clone both of them. Like,
Cortex is a long term storage solution for
Prometheus. So Prometheus has to push data to
Cortex.
So we will have both Prometheus and Cortex
running.
Alright.
Perfect. So let's get this clone done.
Good. It's fast.
There's always that doubt in your head. You're
like, oh crap. How big is this? What's
the connection gonna be like? But when things
just work, I'm a happy man. So
Yeah. Alright. So this is the Cortex cloned
based on we've just seen here. I'm assuming
you just want me to go ahead and
just try and and build this. Yes.
That's all. It's it's simple. It's just a
single binary. Whether it's scaled horizontally or want
to run on a single node, it's always
a single binary. Nice.
And how long does the build take?
It should be pretty quick. Like, the first
build is going to be slow. Yeah. It's
done. It's alright. I think I should do
a fair bit of a
blah blah blah blah blah. Words. I think
I should do a fair bit a fair
amount of hardware on this. Yeah. We've got
64 cores and, you know, 400 gig of
RAM. So it should be snappy.
So I'm assuming now I have a Cortex
binary, which I do. Yes.
And you need to pass some flags, like
you need the config
that's there in the getting started.
Ah. Yeah. So that was You have a
That's years ago. You
have a config already given to you to
get started. Alright. Do you mind if I
just pop that open and we'll take a
quick look? Yeah. Sure.
Okay. This has few stuff which are not
required
right now, but still it's there in the
getting started.
Yeah. Just always nosy, curious. I like to
kinda see. So Yeah. It's it's
alright. Okay. Yeah. Cool. So once we are
done with, like, the hands on, I could
explain what's in the config and the architecture,
what's running inside.
That should be useful.
I I yeah. I expect this error. So
if you if
you can see what network interfaces you have
with IW config, think we need to change
something in the config,
or we will hire we can use LO,
the local
host. If you open the configuration file, we
got to change a small thing.
Okay. So If you go
to the top,
yep, there is
yeah. In like, bottom of this section, there
is ingestion life cycler.
Just below the commented out address,
you can add us no. You can comment
it out. You can add a section called
interface
and assign it to LO.
Just assign it to LO, and it should
be all good, I guess.
Like, by default, it is in.
Yeah. Okay.
Yeah. I hope it works right now.
Yeah. I probably need to know. It's going
make it special.
Let's just make sure I have
have a workaround for this. Hang on.
So what is the
why is it what's the problem? I don't
think I understand exactly what's going on.
It needs a network interface to talk through.
Give me a second.
Why do I not have that handy?
Oh, it's just technically.
Yeah. It it I I've often
I have I had a comment and oof,
big machine. Yeah. I always seem to over
provision, but I think that's just one of
the joys of working for, like, a cloud
company that focuses on bare metal. Like, they
thought their smallest machine
is is still quite a large machine, and
I just I love I know what they
can show
that off a little bit. Yeah.
So I'm just sharing one more
small flag that you can add Yeah. Okay.
Yeah. Let's see. Along with the config file
thing, you can add this following config line.
Okay. So we're just gonna add this ingest
or dot life cycle dot interface.
Yeah. So is that just overriding what's inside
the YAML with Yes. Yep. It's just overriding
the defaults.
So I'm gonna remove that lane from the
config then because it seems that that's causing
I'm I'm I'm guessing. Feel free to correct
me, but it seems like it just doesn't
like that. Yeah.
Where is that low?
I think it's a different file. There are
multiple files.
Yeah. Sorry.
Config blocks.
Alright.
This time, it's gonna work. Right?
Fingers crossed. Ta da. Yay.
So I guess if you could verify the
first log, I guess, it's exposing the port
nine zero zero nine, if I'm right.
If you go a little dot up, it
will be useful to Yeah. 9009.
There we go. Yeah. Yeah. So in the
next step, we can start running Prometheus.
Okay. No worries. Let me just So that
we can push
some data.
Grab this IP address again
so that we don't have to I
guess I could adjust the background data, but
we'll leave it running so the logs are
visible if needed.
So the Prometheus now, are we building that
from source? Or Yeah. We could do it
from source or we could just get the
binary. It should be so it should be
faster.
Yeah. Probably. I mean, don't even know if
Prometheus is available on on the Bintu repository.
We just It
is. Yeah.
Then that means I can just start it
with system d. Okay. Let's do that.
Oh, okay. That might be too outdated hours.
Yeah. It should be fine. But
it would be simpler if we do why
this was because we could change some config
and other stuff. Alright. Okay.
I'll we'll we'll go with your judgment here.
Mine is always wrong. So Yeah. Because I'm
familiar with the repository stuff, so let's go
with that.
Alright. So let's just quickly build that. Hopefully,
it won't take too long either. Yes.
Until then, we can see the config that
we need to
change. Like, there is a default config
where we need to add few stuff.
Okay. So right away, I'm looking at this
bit of YAML, and
I see something that I'm vaguely familiar with,
but it'd be really cool if we could
take the opportunity just to kinda
make sure my knowledge here isn't wrong.
Now I see remote right and this is
something that a lot of people in the
previous community and users are always talk about
premise usability for remote reads and writes. Can
we just cover how Cortex is integrating, or
is that part of your architecture thing? And
I'm just jumping the gun a little bit.
Yeah. So when you talk about all these
long term storage is it has to get
data somehow from the Prometheus.
So Cortex uses the remote right where as
as and when Prometheus scrapes the samples and
store it stores it in its own TSB,
it pushes to this URL.
So this URL turns out to be Cortex
here, so it pushes the samples to the
Cortex. That's how Cortex gets all the samples
that it stores.
So when you have multiple Prometheus instances,
all of them point to the same Cortex
and all of them just push to the
same Cortex.
Okay. So
does that mean the Cortex is just a
backing store? So Prometheus is still doing the
scraping
Yeah. To build Prometheus. Fetching the metrics. Okay.
Yeah. Prometheus is fetching it.
Cortex is like a storing
thing, and you can also query Cortex.
Right.
Excellent.
K. I think I actually understood that.
So prometheus.yaml.
Yaml.
And Yes. Through You can just add the
thing. Just add it. Right. Yeah. Just add
it like that.
You could make one more addition. Like, in
the script config,
you can also scrape Cortex.
Like, just there, you can see scrape config
for Prometheus.
Yeah. We could do that under the name
of Prometheus.
So you were gonna add an you wanted
me to add a new job called Cortex
rather than adding it as a new endpoint
or target to the premier Yeah. Yeah. That
would that would be clearer because you
Yeah. So you gotta keep me right because
I'm I'm a bit of a cowboy when
it comes to this stuff. I'll just well,
I I just wing it. Alright. Cortex.
9009.
Copy to one to many.
And if you go to the top of
the file,
just just so that everything is quicker, you
can change the scrape interval to two seconds
maybe because you don't have wait fifteen seconds
for every sample.
Yeah. And everything should be fine.
Alright.
I trust you. So we have cloned Prometheus.
We built it from source. We should have
the Prometheus binary
Yes. Which we
do. And then we're gonna run it with
the configuration which is modified.
Yes.
I like it when things work.
So Okay. Now
now it should be pushing the data to
yeah. It's remote writing to
what is it? Cortex right now. So if
you could open the Prometheus UI or even
if you want to spin up Grafana and
then we went through that, we can see
if it's actually scraping Cortex and see the
metrics that are ingested in the Cortex.
Yep.
So the by default, this Prometheus binds to
all interfaces or
tried?
Or do I have to do some asset
compilation?
No. It should have been all fine. But
maybe we have to do asset compilation. We
can do that.
Yeah. As I get because all we did
was build the Go command. We haven't actually
did any of the React stuff. Yeah. You
can do a make space assets, and it
should be and rebuild the Prometheus.
Hold on. This is taking a second.
Yep.
I think it's trying to exit nicely.
Yeah.
It's probably trying to end the remote writing
and then come back. Oh, I broke Cortex
with that.
Alright. We'll get it back up in a
second.
I'm not sure what exactly happened there.
Prometheus is ignoring me, so I am gonna
just
p kill.
Yeah.
Something has to happen in my file. There
we go. Right. So make asset. Asset.
App install.
Yeah.
Yarn won't be available
because it adds a special command.
It's weird on the I've been to debian
packages. Yarn is like this random thing.
So I just need to grab the command
over here.
I guess I should actually probably just do
that here so people can see. That's unfortunate.
It's alright. It's a nice quick fix. So
oh,
there is an ABIM two version. Don't don't
give me your nonsense. Do you have like,
could if you could install NPM, you could
install it. Yeah. Yeah. Let's do that. So
install NPM.
I
typing is not my strong suit ever.
That was quick.
Yeah.
The the network connections are pretty solid in
here on these machines.
So it shouldn't take us too long.
Once NPM installed, yeah, we'll just do the
yarn way of doing this then which was
the
there hasn't been too packaged though. But I'm
not gonna fight with that today.
We'll do that.
Is that available in my No.
No.
Let's do x path
equals
path
colon and user local
lib
modules.
Damn it.
I got bin.
No. That is there. Right?
What did I get wrong?
L
s user.
Oh, yarn is a directory
with a bin. Alright. Let's just really
fudge this for now.
Yeah.
Good.
It doesn't have to be pretty. Right? We
just need to get it working. So Yeah.
There's definite there isn't a bin to app
repository, you know, people shouldn't be expected to
follow these horrible steps. But Yeah.
Alright.
It's not really people after this. Okay. Now
one thing I can't make I can't throw
hardware and NPM install, unfortunately. I think this
might take a few seconds.
Yeah.
Not too bad, actually.
Yeah. We don't need much of UI for
Prometheus. It's pretty simple.
Ironically, it may have been faster just to
app get a Stoker fan and now that
I think about it.
Oh, well. Right.
And that's I mean yeah. Sorry. On you
go. Yeah. The getting started has a step
for Grafana.
Oh, it does. Yeah.
Oh, well. We live and we learn.
Even though we have all these codes available,
I'm not I don't even think that Yarn
particularly or NPM or Node particularly uses them.
So
do I need to do a rebuild?
Yeah. Yeah. This is okay. And run the
committers again.
I'll start Cortex first
and then start Prometheus.
And then by magic
today.
Yay. We got there. Okay. Yeah. We can
maybe run a quite like, you can say
rate of
yeah. Cortex
underscore
On the rhythm. Yeah. Cortex.
First.
Ingested
underscore ingested,
yeah, ingested samples total.
Ingested samples. Alright.
And we want to rate that. Rate or
maybe
ten seconds. Ten seconds? Yeah. The
ten seconds should be for the metric and
not the rate.
Oh, I'm feeling it from q l. What
did I get wrong? Like,
the ten seconds and the square bracket should
be inside the circular bracket.
That's for the metric, and you can see
the graph.
There's a graph tab. Yeah.
You can change this time to five minutes,
like, the range of the query for five
minutes. And they're not there. Yeah. Yeah. In
below that. Yeah.
One hour is too much.
There we go. You can see some samples
ingested. And, yeah, it's it's coming from core
it's going to Cortex, and Cortex is storing
everything.
That's sweet.
Excellent.
Good.
Yeah. It's as simple as running a binetal,
like, both Prometheus and Cortex, and you have
a Cortex running.
Okay.
The Cortex runs.
Prometheus handles all the scraping.
It's remote writing into Cortex.
Yes. That's it done. It worked. Right? Yes.
It worked. Okay. What's next? Yep. Maybe I
can explain
a bit of the not exactly the entire
architecture.
We could go back to the previous plan
that we had. I can
show a demo of horizontally scaling Cortex with
other components involved
and then talk about the architecture, and we
could replicate
the thing on your machine. Let's see if
That's good. Yeah. How that works. That's good.
That's good.
Yep. Now I'm gonna share my screen.
If Emma Watson has any questions, feel free
to leave them in the comment section.
Yeah.
There we go. So
I'm reusing the slides by Marco who who
is also an engineer at Grafana Labs and
also Cortex and Thanos maintainer.
So I just took his permission to use
his slides, so I do repeat the work.
So
this is the bare bone Prometheus, which is
scraping from service, and you can query.
And I will jump to what we just
did. By the way, here's Marco.
Yep.
What we just did right now is this
thing. We have a Cortex,
and we when Prometheus is just pushing samples
to Cortex.
And when we want to query, like,
right now, we queried using Prometheus.
You could in the Grafana where you have
a Prometheus data source, you could point it
to Cortex and insert query that. We skip
that step, but I will include that in
the horizontal scaling that we're doing. So right
now, we just had one Cortex.
What we're going to try now is this
thing. We will have multiple Cortex and Prometheus
pushing to them.
And for the object stores, we'll be using
MinIO because we don't want to host,
use the AWS or GCS anything right now.
So
I will jump to my terminal for horizontally
scaling.
Could you just zoom in a little bit
on that? Sure.
Perfect. Thank you.
So
I am using
like, under my account, I'm using the demo.
In the development branch, we already have, like,
prebuilt,
like, pre specified Docker configs, our Docker Compose
config that you can just run a single
command to run the single binary and with
the horizontal scaling.
I just created another demo with a little
more simplified stuff with all the things that
we don't need.
So I'll first run the demo, and we'll
go through what's
there inside.
You have to ignore the
all this part thing because it's just a
mess that I ended up in my environment.
The only thing that's there here is compose
up
before that.
Let's see what all do we have in
this directory.
We We have a compose up compose down
where
compose up just
brings up the docker compose and spins up
multiple stuff.
So I'm just gonna run the compose up.
Okay. Before while this is happening, we can
go through
the config that we have here.
Can you just amend a a little bit
more on that? Yeah.
So let's see what all we are running
in this particular thing. So this is the
Docker Compose config. We are running MinIO
to mimic the ES three or GCS,
and then we are running the Cortex itself.
We are
and I said we need console here,
but why we will get to that in
just a second?
We have a load ban, so that will
be the ingress, and this will pass on
all the things to the Cortex.
And we are running two Prometheus just to
mimic the stuff,
which will be pushing data to Cortex.
If I'm going fast, just
stop me and tell him to reexplain stuff.
We have node exporter so that we can
get some more traffic. Like, Prometheus will be
scraping
Prometheus itself, like meta monitoring. It will be
scraping Cortex and node exporter just for some
additional
data, like, yeah, additional data.
And we are running Grafana so that we
can query Cortex.
And we are running console. Like, we don't
need console right now, but we are anyway
running.
Yeah. And let's
and one small detail to know right now
is we are running
with a replication factor of three,
which means
in this horizontally
scaled stuff, whenever we get a single sample,
it doesn't just go to one single cortex.
It goes to all three. So when you
ran the cortex in your machine, it was
running with replication factor one.
And when we are running with the replication
factor three,
we need to have a quorum
of two, like, two in two Cortex out
of the three should say that I have
returned the sample successfully.
Only then the request can succeed.
So if I move back to my terminal,
you'll see lots of errors which say at
least two replicas
should be required, but it could only find
one.
So what we will
we'll see what's running right now. Yeah. We
have a single Cortex running.
So let's scale it to three so that
these errors go away. Yeah.
We have three Cortex running
and
the logs
it's
getting to a scene state right now, I
guess.
So, basically, what's happening right now is let
me go to the beginning where Prometheus is
scraping and how it's pushing data.
Okay.
Alright. Before they're doing anything, let's see if
it's working properly.
So this is the barebone Cortex
UI that we have. There is nothing special.
If you go to the ingest to ring
status,
it tells you that there are three Cortex
running here,
and all of them have almost equal share
of data that it's incoming.
So that's all we need to know right
now. Let's
go to a fresh Grafana that's running inside.
And we'll add a data source. So Cortex
is %
Prometheus API compatible
even on the read path. Like, read path
and the push path, everything is Prometheus compatible.
Oh, nice. So we will choose Prometheus
as the data source.
And because this Grafana is running inside
the
Docker containers and we have a NGINX load
balancer.
So we can point to that.
And
the Cortex
the Prometheus
API start with
this prefix, so we mentioned that here.
Let me just see
if the data source is working.
So I'll run the same query that you
ran right now, which is
Cortex
ingestion.
And we
we see the samples being ingested here.
If I just go to last five minutes,
something broke.
Where did that?
Okay. We have some samples being ingested, like,
3,000
photon samples
per
cortex. So this is one cortex. This is
second cortex. This is third cortex.
So we have some samples incoming. Let's see.
Let's try to scale up, and,
it'll redistribute
the vocation swing.
Maybe I'm going too fast, but I'm just
going to verify from this scraping everything. It
is.
No. You're okay. It's all good.
Let's scale the Cortex to five.
We add two more.
We got to wait for a few seconds,
and we can check this ring status,
which is available here.
And we have two more incoming. All of
them having almost equal share of 20%.
Let's do last Can
can we explain some of the vocabulary here
then? Like, what is a a context ring?
Yeah. Yeah. We will go deep into that.
Oh, okay. There are lots of thing to
yeah.
As in our time permits, we will go
deep into that. So
we we were writing from two Prometheus replicas,
but and we are actually running two Prometheus
replicas, which means it's But
Cortex also
has the support for it where it deduplicate
stuff.
So if I just quickly go through
the config,
we are saying that enable
and we use console only for the where
it elects one of the Prometheus as the
leader and only one of them is scraped.
And if you go to the Prometheus config,
it has a label called replica
and a cluster.
Replica and a cluster. So for common cluster,
it selects one of the replicas. That's how
it works.
And if you go to the tracking
status,
you can see which Prometheus was selected among
the two.
So we are actually demoing
like, these are two Promethe
I going to the load balancer,
getting deduplicated
here,
and we're just,
spreading out the Cortex.
Now you said you we will talk about
the ring. Why not?
Yeah. So
you need some kind of logic so that
it can spread
the rights
equally to
all the Cortex. We actually have that explained
in one of the slides here. Why don't
I reuse it?
So
let's say we have some random ring like
this and instead of 10,
when we have three court five cortex right
now,
we will have five
entries in the ring saying cortex one to
five.
And
in the config
we mentioned,
we want to have number of tokens as
512.
So it'll randomly select some number between,
zero to the int max 64.
And
whenever a series is incoming, we hash the
series,
and the hash is between zero to int
max 64.
And based on,
like, which ingest through holds a token for
this particular hash,
that sample goes to that particular ingestors. Did
that make sense?
Yes. Let me can I try and then
repeat that back to you in my really
naive understanding and we'll see if Yeah? Sure.
Can we go back to the diagram with
the load balancer and the Cortex in it?
Yeah.
I'll go with this one. That one. Yeah.
Right. Okay. So
we're
I I just wanna make sure I got
this right. We run multiple Prometheus,
each scraped in the same target. Let's assume
it's a bit on a Kubernetes cluster so
that we have higher Yeah. High availability. If
one of those Prometheus goes away, it's still
being scraped by at least one. Yes. Those
prometheus are being consumed by the Cortex.
And the Cortex, it's not actually if if
I understand it correctly, it's not actually doing
deep duplication explicitly,
but it's actually doing deep duplication by hashing
the metrics and then it's charting them across
the many cortex. Is that right? I think
I think I got you confused here.
So the when Prometheus is pushing samples to
the cortex,
it has some labels additional labels which says
I am from replica one, I'm from replica
two from the same cluster,
and we have configured
Cortex to enable HAD duplication.
So even before we do that hashing thing,
Cortex elects one of the Prometheus
as the leader among those two, which we
see in the tracking
status.
So it will blindly
discard
all the sample sets coming from one of
the Prometheus and clone the accept samples from
second Prometheus and remove the replica labels that
we have.
So after that step, we do the hashing.
Ah, okay. Okay. I gotcha.
Okay. Yeah. Now we can go ahead with
what you're explaining. Okay. So there is the
de duplication based on the labels that has
been added by the Prometheus, the it's then
hashed and then assigned
and then replicated across the Cortex is based
on the replication rules that are in the
configuration.
Yes.
Alright.
I'm with you now.
Nice.
So let's say among this five in just
us,
the hash went to,
let's say, the Cortex number three. Let's say
we have only five right now because we
ran five.
Let's say the sample went to the cortex
three, so it will be given to cortex
three, cortex four, and cortex five.
And in case a car in the cortex
has to crash, let's say four is crashed,
it will still try to write to three
of them. But once it writes to two
of the cortex, it will return the request
saying that, hey. I have
I'm done with the quorum of two out
of three, I can return. But it it
will still try try to write with try
to write to another Cortex, which will be
the next Cortex, which is one.
So no no matter what, it'll try to
write to
three Cortex, which is the replication factor, while
satisfying at least the Quorum.
So that's how the replication works.
And when you are querying,
it'll actually like, there is something called query
component. It'll query all the Cortex for the
samples because you don't know where you might
have gaps because of maybe cortex rolling out
or some cortex is down. So when you
hit a query, it goes to all five
cortex.
All five cortex get like, you hit a
query to one of the cortex. It will
send a query to all five cortex for
the query, and the sample goes to one
of the Cortex where it originated.
It makes and matches the duplicate sample, and
you finally get back
the data to your Grafana.
Awesome. Very cool.
So see the
the usage of console here, is that because
you're running this in Docker Compose? Like, I'm
wondering if if Cortex is running Kubernetes,
does it use the least capabilities there for
the leader election without console? That's that's a
good question.
So
console
yeah. Cortex
either needs console or HCD for
this
d d like, this tracker status, whatever you
are seeing here right now is from the
console.
So for to elect a leader among the
H a Prometheus,
you need either console or HCD right now.
And
okay, I'm just hitting wrong tabs.
this ring, initially, we used to store even
this ring in console, but now it's it
uses you can use gossip. The way we
ran right now, the Cortex, it uses gossip
to communicate among the Cortex,
and the ring data is just propagated
lazily to all the Cortex so that
you can do the
replication
properly. Yeah. Console is only required for h
a u n. If you are not using
h a, you don't need console.
Ah, okay. Perfect.
Nice.
Yeah.
Do you want to dive more deeper, or
do you want to get hands on first
on your machine?
Okay. Let's
I mean, I think the problem with diving
deeper is that we're limited by my knowledge.
So why don't we get hands on? And
if if anything that people have in the
comments, we can try and tackle that. Now
we have had a
which has been tackled by I'm assuming one
of your colleagues.
Rick asked, how does the member list ring
works with Cortex processes split out? Where should
the join members value be set? Contacts using
help chart supported there. I mean, I don't
understand that question, but if you do, maybe
you could try and explain that.
So should I point join members to all
Cortex or
I think there's a
config
somewhere here. Yes.
So in the member list, we are saying
get the DNS records of Cortex.
So it asked the DNS for all the
entries of Cortex.
And on the seven nine four six port,
like, it is the default port that we
use for member list. You can change it
in the Cortex config.
Okay. I don't think I was sharing my
screen. My bad. Let me go through that
again. Yeah. I was just about to ask.
Yeah. I was just
explaining.
There you go. Okay. Yeah.
So in the config, we have this member
list stuff where we are saying,
take the records of this Cortex because in
Docker Compose, we are running it as Cortex.
So the DNS center will be entry will
be as Cortex.
And
in the config, we say, take the DNS
records of Cortex
and do all the gossip things that you
want on the port 9746.
If you are wondering why 9746,
let me go to the configuration.
Let's go to configuration file. I can just
search 46,
and it just happens to be the default
that we used.
You can change this
member list con config to bind to any
port
and then use
that port here. So that's how you specify.
So that DNS plus Cortex, is that doing,
like, a a headless lookup fetching all the
IP addresses that resolve to Cortex and then
discovering them that way. Right? So okay. I'm
doing gossip for this port.
Okay. Got it. I hope that answers.
Yeah. I I I I understand that. I
I don't know if it answers the question
specifically, but, Rick, feel free to to get
back in touch. And I know that has
also replied, so hopefully that covers that. Why
don't we get a hands on just hands
on again, and then we'll we'll take it
from there. So I should be able to
replicate
this.
Right? Yes. That's that's what we're gonna do.
So Yeah. You might want to now clone
my demo because the one in the upstream
is little different.
Alright. Let me SSH onto the first node
again.
And we wanna clone
h two c s github dot com code
sum/Cortex.
Cortex.
Right.
And a Cortex code sum.
Alright. Yeah.
You go to Cortex.
Yeah.
Just always my typing that lets me down.
Okay.
So You can go into development
and then
oh, why do yeah. You should fetch the
demo branch. My bad. The master sync with
the upstream.
Demo. Right?
Yeah.
Okay. And
you can just do dot slash compose up,
and everything should be up and running. But
we have to scale up Cortex
as we saw before.
Okay. And that's just gonna run that's which
we've already went over. So it's gonna run
many of which gives us an s three
compatible
blocks blob storage on this. We run Cortex
with the configuration.
We're running a load balancer for the Cortex.
Yes. And then we have our two Prometheus
which is our h a scraping. We've got
a node export of which I'm assuming we're
just grabbing some metrics from. And then we
have Grafana and we have Console. So we
we covered all this. We can run compose
up.
And it's just gonna pull down some docker
images. But again Yeah. It should be pretty
quick, I hope.
Yep.
And I'll just put that repository back on
the screen. So if people wanna play with
us own time, you can clone that repository,
check out the demo branch, and run this
yourself.
Yeah. Also, if you want to just run
the upstream
demos of con Docker Compose, you could also
do that. It's straightforward.
It It explicitly mentions
Cortex replicas, but in this demo, you can
dynamically scale up and scale down. That's the
only difference.
Okay. Cool.
So is the
there we go.
So the ports are being used. So I
should probably shut down the other stuff. Yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah. It's using the Prometheus port nine zero
nine zero.
Cortex.
Yeah. Cortex was already done. This is.
Yeah.
Okay. Cool. Yeah. So let's just
run that again.
Alright. And it's up. Yes. So we want
should be getting some error message. Yes. We
want to scale up the Cortex.
The error message here is just saying that
could only find one and we need at
least two. And that's just so that we
have a core among the Cortex cluster. Right?
Yes. Yeah.
So if I go to the Cortex code
some development
demo,
and then we could do a docker compose
scale Cortex
five. Right?
Yeah. We can do five.
It should Cortex equals to five, I guess.
Ah, cortex equals five.
And then we should see I guess it
might just take a few seconds, but the
error message has gone away. We can see
now
other things and stuff happening. So Yeah.
Yeah. And to see everything in action, you
can open
this IP on port a t t on
a browser and see
all the Cortex running and the status.
Oh, why is it back gateway?
Can
I see the terminal if it said something?
We're getting our connection refused upstream.
No.
That's wrong.
I just ran that.
You could try again. I'm not sure. Let's
let's take a look. Right? So we could
do docker compose p s. Let's just make
sure everything is running.
Yes. Everything is fine.
Just see. Load parents search. Yeah.
Yeah. It's definite let's see.
I'm usually good at fixing broken stuff, so
let me see.
So is there something to worry about? Should
we just is this a red heading? But
we have No. That's fine. That's totally fine.
K. So the only problem we have right
now is
engine x. So let's
take a look at what's going on with
this load balancer setup. So if I do
a docker compose e x c
load balancer bash.
We'll take a look at the engine x
config.
And let's see. Cortex dot YAML.
Of course. Let's just.
Yep. NGINX
config. Yeah. NGINX config should be.
Yeah. It's pointing to Cortex.
Okay. So it's just an approximate pass to
Cortex as a DNS name. So let's curl
Cortex.
And that looks okay. Right?
Yes.
If if you do Cortex eight eighty.
No. Cortex should be on port 80, but
Yeah.
So from the hosts,
let's try
local host eighty eighty,
that gateway.
That's interesting.
Because we are pointing the load balances 82
local host eighty eighty.
Yeah. Okay. So why is NGINX unhappy
even though it looks like to me it
should
Yeah. Be working
upstream.
That is really weird.
I'm gonna restart NGINX. I'd I think we
want to compose down once because it failed
initially or did it not? I don't remember.
Yeah. I guess it
yeah. Let let's do that then before I
start just kicking things. Okay. Yeah. You can
do dot
slash compose down.
Yeah. Dot compose down.
Yeah. I'm trying my best. My brain says
one thing, my fingers type another. It's
a common problem.
Alright. Let's run this back up again.
And we have to scale up again. Hopefully,
everything is fine this time.
Yeah. Let's scale this up again.
K.
Cortex.
Quotes on development demo.
Oh, let's just scale.
Cortex equals five.
Alright. So we should see those adders disappear
again.
This looks good.
There. Yay.
Transient
error.
Yeah. Alright. So what we're seeing got ingested
ring status,
we'll show you that we are running five
of them.
Alright. I mean, that's
pretty simple then to scale horizontally.
Like, I mean, can I take any number
there? Like, if I'd scale this let's say
I do 50. I I that's probably a
really stupid number. I'm no instantly regretting that.
Yeah.
Let's not scale down now because scaling down
requires you to scale down one at a
time.
So that's going to take a lot of
time, so let's play with 50 right now.
Okay. Sorry. I should've run that past you
first, but, I mean, that's pretty cool. We've
just scaled up our Cortex to 50 notes.
And they're they're slowly coming in active.
So Yes.
Nice.
Okay.
So yeah. If we submit a little bit.
Alright. Good. So I think
still a couple pending, but it's it's getting
there. So Yeah. We have 50 Cortex running.
So that's pretty cool. Like Yeah. I could
just scale that to the and what are
the scaling constraints on Cortex then? Like, when
do I scale up Cortex? Is is it
dependent on how much data I have coming
in? Does it ingest control, flow rate, like,
cardinality? What are the the constraints there? So
there are a few things. Like, one is
the right, which
the like, I can actually go through the
architecture right now and talk
why when would you
split it into microservices
mode and what component is hit by what.
Yeah. Go somewhere. That would be great. Yeah.
I'll actually share my screen. It will be
easier to
show the architecture with that.
Yeah.
Am I is my screen visible now? Yep.
It is. We can see the hash string.
Yeah.
So
where is the overall architecture?
Sweet.
Yeah.
So
when
you've ran a single Cortex binary,
it is actually running all these components inside
a single processor.
So these are all the components that you
have. So in the right path, we encounter
distributor and ingestor.
The ingestor is the final place where their
data goes. It stores it in the memory.
Ingestors
have the tokens, etcetera.
And distributor reads the
ring,
determines which ingest us it has to go
to,
and then it just sends the data to
the ingestor.
So if we take the link page when
we have five Cortex, or let's say now
we have 10 Cortex, when you hit a
Cortex for ingesting the sample, you hit the
distributor
component,
and it selects three of the Cortex, and
it goes to the ingest component of the
Cortex.
So that's the right path.
And when we go to the read path,
the query front end does some query optimization
of, like, splitting queries into multiple queries to
parallelize the queries and all other stuff.
And then sends
those parallel queries to a component called
Querier.
So Querier
actually directly uses the PromQL engine that we
have in Prometheus, so it's %
PromQL compliant.
So courier
ask for yeah. When ingestor has data which
is old, it pushes to the or the
objects that they have. So Querier gets the
recent data from the ingested old data from
the store gateway. Store gateways design the component
to interact with the store the
object store. Querier gets the data, runs the
queries, sends back the data to query front
end. And because query front end gets the
data back from multiple queries, it, again, merges
the data and sends back to the
querying tool of your choice. Compactor is just
another service which merges all the data here.
So now talking about
where would you like, all that I explained
right now, does that make sense?
Yeah. I mean, I have one
question looming in my head, and it's that
we're scaling Cortex as a single binary. Is
that how I scale it? Or can I
build those components in isolation? Do I scale
them all together?
Yes. I was going to get to that
thing. So let's say what are the
bottlenecks
when you scale,
like, run Cortex at huge scale, and how
do we split this into multiple things.
So in the right if you have only
a right heavy Cortex,
then the distributor and ingestor will be heavily
loaded.
And if you query anything because it's a
single context running, your queries might suffer because
of lots of rights.
Now let's see the other way around. You
have lots of heavy queries running, expanding all
days, touching all the Cortex instances.
And then
because of that, it takes lots of CPU,
your rights are suffering here.
So you could scale out her Cortex horizontally
with the single binary as much as you
can as long as both of these are
working fine. But when one of the read
path or write path is affecting the other,
there, she would want to split this into
multiple components.
So what's beautiful is you use this
single binary itself to run multiple components.
For example,
I have Cortex. By default, it has something
called target equals to all,
which is the single binary that we ran
right now, which runs all the components inside
the single process.
So you could just say just run the
ingest.
Ah. And you don't don't want other components.
Nice. That that way you can
yeah. I think we
have yeah.
That way, this is, again, a Cortex binary
Cortex binary Cortex binary,
but you are running distributor
in just a separately.
And you get to one of the distributor.
You have a load balancer in front. Like,
you can have this is a multitenant system,
but it
Cortex does not itself
implement any kind of authentication, so you need
some kind of authentication
in front. You go to one of the
distributors,
and everything is like before. You can consider
this as one of the Cortex, which takes
the sample,
flushes the blocks, it goes to the main
IO. And in the query path, again, this
is a Cortex binary, but target as query
front end.
Another Cortex binary target as courier.
So
and once you have this architecture up,
if you have if you are getting more
and more rights and not much reads,
you could just scale up these distributors and
these ingestors.
And
one rule of thumb that you could follow
is what we follow is you can limit
the amount of memory each ingest is taking
or the amount of
series
each ingest is handling
based on your machine size. So whenever you
are hitting that limit, you scale out the
investors. And if distributors are not able to
send samples to investors, you scale out the
distributors.
And query,
yeah, query it. The more queries you are
getting, you just scale out the quarriers query
front end, you can just do it to
write on. We cannot scale
out query front end right now, but we
would be able to do it soon, I
guess. But I I guess that's pretty standard
practice. Like, if I sync up at all
the production systems I've operated over the years,
like, the right path is where the traffic
is. You know, the queries of the dashboards
that we open when things go wrong and
not necessarily something we'd we'd have to, you
know, scale independently.
Yeah. Yeah. But when what happens is when
you have this long term storage,
a few folks like to
have a dashboard open all the time, which
might span multiple days. So it's constantly hitting
the server with heavy queries.
If you are running if you have one
of such users, then you could see yourself
splitting. Like, you could even have a binary
running both distributor and ingest. It's not like
you want to run a single where if
you want to split, you don't need to
run a single component
in in a binary. You could have distributor
ingest as a single binary and only split
out courier outside.
You can also do that.
Okay.
So can we there's there's one thing that
we've not really
looked at yet, but we are running many.
Right? So all of our data right now
has been stored on an s three compatible
store. Right?
Yeah. If I said it stays in the
industry, in the memory, and the writer log.
After some time, yes, it goes to the
s three compatible storage
or GCS or anything else. So stays on
the right head log until it has to
be flushed to disk, and that flush to
disk is entered to s three compatible store?
Yes.
Okay. Cool.
I like that. It's very cool. Yeah. And
what's beautiful is we are reusing
the
Prometheus data storage. Like, Prometheus has blocks of
data.
So we are having a we are recreating
the exact same blocks in these ingests, and
we are just flushing those blocks in the
as compatible stories on GCS.
Okay.
And as Cortex
like, on the query side then, is that
doing any sort of cache to avoid lookups
on the on the store? Correct? Yeah.
So the query front end has cache, which
cache cache is based on the time range
and the query that you have.
So it can also do partial querying, like,
for in Grafana dashboards,
you can
have
yeah. You can when you refresh after every
five or ten seconds, you don't need to
query for the entire range, but you just
need to query for the last few data
points.
So this cache even takes care of that.
So we just query the only thing that
we require.
Nice. That's I like it.
Yeah. And
you also cache, like
like, couriers needs to fetch fetch the data
from store gateway and ingestor.
So courier also caches
all the data that it can fetch from
these. It query front end caches the final
result. Couriers caches the raw data, so we
just cache everything that we can.
Cool.
Excellent.
Is there
anything you wanna cover then before we
Yeah. I would yeah. For users who want
to
try out, like, I will just switch to
master
just to show what's there in upstream. If
you want to, like,
run these docker comp docker compose stuff in
your own machine,
in the
development,
we have
three things already set up for you. I'm
not really sure about this thing.
But the single binary mode will run the
individual
cortex
in a horizontally scaled, which you will have,
I guess, two or three cortex running,
but in a single binary mode.
And if you want to run
this setup where you want all the individual
components separately,
so you choose this.
There, if I want to quickly have a
peek,
Yep. Here, you will be
turning the distributor
and just everything else separately.
So if you want to play around with
single binary
or even the everything split out version, you
have it ready.
Yeah. Alright. I guess that's it.
Nice.
So let's
let's
let's finish with like a
I'm trying to think like a pragmatic approach
to people with their their metrics. Right? The
vibe I'm getting from the conversation and what
we've seen here is that it's probably realistic
that people are gonna start with Prometheus in
their cluster, And then there's gonna be a
certain point where they want to then bring
in Cortex for the Yes. The durability, the
high availability,
the multi tenancy, which is really cool Yes.
And all these things. Like, so is that
the best approach for people to take is
to, you know, run Prometheus and then when
x y z happens, that's when you go
right. You you need to start bringing in
Cortex now. Yeah. If you have small Prometheus
installations and
like, if you care about
centralized view and all the things that we
discussed right now, Only at that point, you
may want to start looking at Cortex.
Until then, if the scale is small, you
could
be all good with Prometheus because Prometheus scales
really good.
But but but vertically. Right? That's when we
talk about Yeah. We're
talking about Yeah. You know, vertical. So if
you can pull
loads of really strong firmware hardware out, then
cool. Right? Exactly. This is gonna get you
a long way. Exactly. Nice. Okay. And the
does it make sense to just even adopt
Cortex purely for the s three compatible back
end as well? Like, you know, I'm assuming
that just make them enough of a selling
point where people wanna be able to rotate
the hardware and still have that back end
data So s three could be a really
good stop gap for that too. Yes. You
could just have Cortex just as a,
you can say, backup data which takes the
data. But you could also have a look
at Thanos. Like, if you just want the
data to be backed up somewhere, Thanos has
more simplified
thing where it just shifts the block to
your s three compatible storage. And if you
want to query later, you can just add
one more component.
Wow. That's that's
completely
serendipitous.
Yeah. That's a is that I have Thanos
one week today on the show. We're taking
a look at that there. So, you know
Yeah. People can come and take a look
at that. Yeah. Both have different
slightly different approaches and different goals
and you have huge scale and want proper
centralize with multitenancy Cortex makes proper sense there.
Awesome.
Any final thoughts before we finish up for
today?
Just try it out. It's pretty cool. Like,
the initially, when Cortex came, the
everyone saw the architecture diagram, they got scared.
It's pretty very complex. But if you saw
it here, you could just do dot slash
Cortex and you have Cortex up and running.
Yes. There I mean, I'll personal experience here.
There is an intimidation
factor when you're so many of the talks
are really you know, they go deep into
Cortex and all the different components, and it
can be a little bit intimidating, especially when
you see people talking about the Cassandra components
and all this other stuff that can come
in. But I think what we've seen today
from your demos and from what we did
hands on is that that's all optional. Like
you can get started by running the single
binary and running for me Yeah. Something
that we're all comfortable with. And Yeah. You
can then layer on those extra components. You
can bring in console when you need h
a and d duplication. You can bring in
s three when you want
extra storage options. You can bring in Cassandra
when that is available to you. So I
think Yeah. You don't even need Cassandra.
You don't at all need Cassandra with us.
Right?
Yeah. I think I'll avoid that whenever possible,
to be fair. So
Yeah. Alright. That
was awesome. I I'm really impressed. I think
it's a fantastic project, and I'm really looking
forward to to seeing what comes next.
Thank you for joining me today, Ganesh. It's
been an absolute pleasure. I hope people take
a lot of value from this and have
a great day.
Yep. Thanks for having me. Cheers. Adios.